I want to turn the phone line right now
a friend of the program back here and
man did he give absolutely every single
Knick fan a starts to say the least when
he tweeted out two days ago that Isiah
Thomas was a dark horse candidate to run
the Knicks and the Knicks organization
something that moments ago Isiah Thomas
tweeted out that he's not interested in
he likes being at NBA TV Frank Isola
from the New York Daily News here on the
show how you doing Frank I rich I want
to thank you for having me on the show
with Brett Favre and Jon Hamm puts a lot
of pressure on me let everybody in your
audience must be thinking really you're
having this guy on on a daily net Brett
Bachman on hand so all right you putting
me on the spot you're making me look bad
but I'll go no no Frank you're looking
at it the wrong way I'm making you look
good okay you're on the show with those
guys that I saw the tweet I was like oh
my god I can't believe it it'll be on
today you you set me up didn't you
they're honored you Frank you're not on
with them they're on with you I guess I
should look at that all events to get
you back as for as far as a tie I do
find it funny first of all that came
from somebody Nick organization called
them a dark horse candidate didn't say
that he's going to get the job didn't
say that he's lobbying for the job
but I did have to laugh a little bit
when Isaiah sent out a tweet saying that
he's not interested in the job you could
be kidding me with that one he really
came back to Madison Square Garden to
run the Liberty which I'm sure he likes
doing but I think a guy like that
considering how everything ended in New
York the first time he's been dying for
another opportunity to run any team in
the NBA
any of the any of the 30 teams right now
there's a vacancy in New York if you go
back to Jim Bohlen statement from six
years nobody said I will continue to
solicit ideas views about basketball you
will always be a friend of mine a friend
of the organization so to think that
like Isiah Thomas is sitting back saying
now I'm not really going to go for it
right now maybe the next time the job
becomes available I understand why he's
doing that he doesn't want to make it
seem like you know he's leaking
something out or he's lobbying for it
but you know I'm gonna go with what this
person the organization said that you
can never rule him out and that he's a
dark horse candidate so then where does
it currently stand best you can tell
David Griffin is being brought in to
talk about the general manager ship and
I'm not even sure
how far along that is I mean obviously
he would be a candidate your life thing
with the Knicks always is there always
has to be some kind of connection here
and when it was Isaiah Thomas that was
Magic Johnson turning the job down and
telling Steve Mills and Jindal you
should hire Isaiah
then when Donnie Walsh got the job that
was really the lead kind of pushing Jim
Don Sanderson hire either I dive in with
you Donnie Walsh or Jerry Cohen to let
them come in experienced guys well
established at the moment then when it
was Phil Jackson it was Jim Dolan's
relationship with Irving Azoff the
famous manager of the rock band The
Eagles who's friendly now we can go on
their own business together
he's the one that broke was that he also
Jackson so tomato always has to be some
kind of connection and as of right now
to me there is no connection with David
Griffin unless maybe the Knicks are
taking a to somehow someway we bring in
Dave script and who knows maybe at some
point we can get LeBron I think that's a
bit of a reach right now so there always
has to be a connection and I really
can't find one between the Knicks and
David Griffin just remember the job has
been available a couple of times why did
they go after RC Buford that's the best
in the business and it can blow
everybody out of the water with an offer
so if you not that's not to say that
David Griffin can't do the job but why
not call RC Buford as well so there
always has to be some kind of link and
right now I can't come up with one
between the Knicks of David crypt
talking Knicks with the man who is the
honey that brought the bees named Brett
Favre Andy Samberg and Jon Hamm to this
edition the Rich Eisen show they're
being Frank Isola here on the program so
Frank let's let's talk Carmelo because
that's the piece that actually is of
national concern over the next 24 to 48
hours unless there really is no there
there would still gone what do you think
Claire well yeah if there is someone I
think Phil Jackson was right about this
I think right now with the way the
Knicks are near stage is developmental
where Carlos and his career who would be
bested that they both split up the
problem was the way that phil jackson
handled it trying to kind of publicly
embarrass carmelo anthony and give
carmella credit he played this one very
wisely he never spoke up in the media he
has come completely on the ground since
the season ended and when all the dust
settle
he's still standing here and Phil
Jackson is God he has a good
relationship with Jen dawn so I think
the big thing now would be can you work
out some trade but I think if your goal
and went to Carmelo and asked them hey
bleep let's let's do this I think this
would be best for both of us I think
that's something that chlorella would
listen to but the problem is you know
what the next man's never seem to
understand is promo
when you consider that contract doesn't
have that much value it's a gigantic
number so that means you have to take
back big-time salary it's a trade picker
so he gets an additional eight million
dollars his body is showing signs as
well you got listen there are tons of
things in the league that will want him
but it's very difficult to make a deal
on top of the fact that he has no trade
clause so maybe at some point it will
end in the buyout that's what Phil
Jackson wanted to do
that's what Carmelo wanted but Jim Dolan
didn't wanna pay basically 50 million
dollars to make one of Phil Jackson's
mistakes go away well you could get Phil
Jackson 24 million dollars to make him
goal and ultimately that's what happens
well and then you wrote an excellent
piece in the new york daily news today
frank entitled inside Phil Jackson's
tumultuous three years as Knicks
president and I'd like you to tell some
of the stories that you recounted in
your piece in today's Daily News start
what one thing that just left out at me
was a film that we all know still wanted
Steve Kerr as his first coach when he
first joined the Knicks organization and
then that fell apart I always thought
because Kerr was just smart enough to
stay away from that hot mess of an owner
but I'm reading I'm reading in your
article James Dolan said no to Steve
Kerr wanted no part of Steve Carr told
Phil to move on from Steve Kerr I I
think that Jim know and made it known
that he wasn't that crazy about that
hire and you always have to remember his
car before he got back into the NBA was
working as an analyst with TNT
right and Marv Albert was kind of like a
sworn enemy of Jim Dolan you gotta be
kidding me good not telling you and I
think the Gordon was worried he's got
you know the direct pipeline like Marv
Albert a lot of things to do over there
sometimes could be media related now
that's not to say he's going to put his
foot down sake absolutely not you're not
doing this but I do though this speaker
was a little bit leery about going to
Madison Square Garden
and working under Jim dawn I think and
also very Academy Steve Kerr as the head
coach and eventually let's think about
think about this they offered Derek
Fisher more money than they offered
Steve Kerr so Phil's second choice kind
of better offers than his first choice
guy what does that tell you and in terms
of the media strategy you told an
interesting story about when Phil was
introduced and how you were not able to
ask questions at his introductory press
conference like trying to get here exert
Gardner said this long-running feud with
the Daily News over over a lot of things
you might add like six reporters there
and I thought it was interesting you
know filled that up that day we need to
he's being introduced to the media they
didn't like the rotunda right in the
front of Madison Square Garden on that
March day was kind of cool outside Glenn
Frey he unfortunately the late great one
fried and was there at the press
conference as part of kind of Phil
Jackson's group and so got up there and
unsolicited he brought up you know kind
of repairing the relationship between
the organization and the media he
thought that was going to be important
so clearly people had gotten to Phil you
know his friends around the league it's
all the listen you know you got to go in
there and do things the right way but as
soon as Philopator talking a member of
the Madison Square Garden got up and he
was moderating the Q&A and he was
deciding who gets to ask questions in
the neighborhood for example The Daily
News asked a question something
commercial for hang on a second I mean
still just said his coke about you know
a clean slate repairing the relationship
and yet you know the guards are still
trying to settle old scores by the way
that told me you know what he's going to
have a lot of power here but not all the
power that he thinks he's going to get
and then of course if you remember maybe
like two months after that still wanted
to make some changes to the medical
staff in jindo and homeless and you're
in charge of a school operation these
medical people work for me they're going
to stay exactly where they are so they
were always that's not to say that Jim
Don didn't want to do a lot of things
but yeah when I say full autonomy that
that certainly has its limit any other
thing which I thought was interesting
was you know Phil's in a dedication to
the triangle Sam when we talk about
building a culture in New York is going
to be the triangle and last year he went
to visit a free agent and he wanted to
show the player you know how he wanted
to
NIC's to play and how he envisioned this
free agent sitting in and he was
fumbling off the computer and Stephen
looks had to kind of come around there
get to the sitting at the dining room
table in the players house and Steve
Mills got the computer to work and he
actually was showing this free agent
footage of the 90s goals and then
running the triangle and Larson both had
unbelievable success with the Bulls in
the 90s a game has changed just a little
bit I might you know you might have been
better off showing footage of the 2015
Golden State Warriors in the way that
they play considering they've been to
three straight finals and won two of
them so I kind of think he was part of
those thing what he wanted to prove to
everybody that the trial could work we
all know it can work it worked
it won of all those titles but the
league is also change and I think build
kind of stubbornness and unwillingness
to change also hurt him in the long run
so in the end me in the long run
knowledge it's over Frank I solo Daily
News do you think Phil failed because he
was ill-equipped to do the job that he
did or the culture of Madison Square
Garden bagged another one yep you you
said it rich it's actually both of them
and I think for Phil Jackson you know I
think he he believes that he's smarter
than everybody and I think when you're
taking over a job like that because
you're a great coach because it
automatically means you're going to be a
great executive and you executive and
you really have to get your hands dirty
and looking trades are made how many
times you see these trades being made
say you know between the Spurs and the
Atlanta Hawks then you start thinking
all right that's right Mike Budenholzer
used to work for great politics it's
kind of a relationship business until as
a coach you kind of liked looking down
upon everybody and saying what the heck
of you guys I'm winning all these
championships but in that kind of role
you need to have relationships with
other executives you need to you know on
foot it's an ugly part of the job for a
lot of executives you have to have
relationships with agents and I don't
think that supplier agents on talk Matt
and Phil never really wanted any part of
that job everything with Tim was
triangle and think about it rich
whenever things were going to poorly for
the next which was often the thing that
he always leaned on was the triangles
when the Knicks came back from the
all-star break last year the seasons
headed nowhere he's not going to be able
to make any trades he basically tells
Jeff hornacek we're going full-blown
triangle right now and hit players in
he was involved in some of the drills he
always thought of himself as the coach
and you the players pick up on that that
you can't coach the team from your you
know courtside seat penrose up right at
center court you can't do it it's not
going to work and I think all if you
know who he'll work switch and all these
you know jobs where guys get fired these
coaches executives it's never just one
thing it's always a series of things and
he'll fill think you know kind of
behaving like a coach and really never
embracing the job of being executive I
think that also her last one for you
Frank of the free agency period as we
all know opens tonight what do you think
will be tomorrow night Saturday night at
the top of the headline stack in NBA
news what do you think I think going
over to the Boston Celtics is very real
I think Paul Millsap will be on the move
from Atlanta so that's a big name free
agent I think that Blake Rickman will
return to the Clippers now that he's
going to be kind of the guy but I think
the big one will be going over to the
Boston Celtics I think that's why the
Celtics weren't involved with Jimmy
Butler so now if Gordon Hayward ends up
there and if you're the Indiana Pacers I
still think the Pacers are sitting a
pretty good position I understand you
Paul George's in his last year but on
Indiana what can I get for my best
player and the first team I'm going to
call out character in my conference I'm
going to call the Boston Celtics is a
lawless traffic if you're getting rid of
your best player you're rebuilding so
you might as well get young players
draft expecting that has the most of
them that would be the Boston Celtics on
a bond Danny Ainge I'm thinking to
myself I know Paul George says here he
wants to play in LA and all this stuff
it's Boston will get him here for a year
we'll show them how great it is how much
the city loves its professional athletes
here Kevin Garnett kind of went kicking
screaming there two weeks until he
finally agreed to that trade and he
loved every minute of it
so maybe Boston it'll be interesting do
Danny Ainge has been taking a couple of
shots since the everything that happened
with the draft but you know within ten
days if he can end up with Gordon
Hayward and Paul Jordan I think those
are both certainly in play that would
look a lot different for him and the
Boston so Frank have a great fourth of
July thanks for calling and do Rick tell
ine-san Berg and Jon Hamm I said what's
not [ __ ] you guys let's try catch
all of the daily news so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you liked that video be sure
to download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to